[Music]
hello there November is a beast of a
month for new games the Christmas Rush
begins and so many video games are vying
for your attention like usual I've
looked through all the offerings to
recommend the best games at all price
ranges including three free games thanks
to Nikon for sponsoring this video we'll
be looking at the latest installment in
the long-running Warhammer 40K series
later in the video you ready let's do
this
like I could start anywhere else God of
War Ragnarok is finally here following
on from 2018's Game of the Year in which
Greek demigod Kratos travels to the Nars
realm to escape the horrors of his past
Father and Son Kratos and atreus are
pursued by the vengeful freyja and the
God of Thunder himself Thor reviewers
have already told us Ragnarok Builds on
every element of the previous game
improved visuals evolved combat deeper
story and impactful RPG elements for
example kratos's Shield changes the way
we play The Dauntless Shield rewards
those with perfect parrying timing
whereas The Stonewall Shield is designed
to absorb attacks until it can be used
against enemies the weapons the armor
and the runes we choose will all change
the way we play if you need a story
recap I'll have one later this week and
there's a super simple recap option in
ragnarok's main menu to be doubly sure
do your best to avoid spoilers God of
War Ragnarok releases on 4 and PS5 on
Wednesday November the 9th
for those who want something less
serious may I recommend Goat Simulator 3
wow where do I start Goat Simulator is a
Sandbox game crammed full of secrets and
hidden activities defined everywhere
while stringing a combo together like a
Tony Hawk game yet breaking things is
the metric the game's official
description is equally as weird and
wonderful expect events and PCs to mess
with physics status effects Collectibles
Easter eggs lies betrayal and heartbreak
we've already seen more customization in
their trailer than most games have at
all and look we can drive vehicles and
we can be a rhino and should you be
tempted to play Goat Simulator 2 you
should know that it doesn't exist the
devs wanted to go from one to three just
to mess with you Goat Simulator 3 allows
4 player cooperative play which is great
as this is a budget game it only costs
30. 30 Euros or 25 pounds here in my
homeland look out for it on November
17th on PS 5 Xbox series and PC
any Sonic the Hedgehog fans in the house
have you seen Sonic Frontiers a 3D
action platformer which takes the Blue
Blur into the open world genre after
jumping through a wormhole and being
separated from his friends Sonic is
stuck on this island the over-the-top
soundtrack and the neon color backdrops
have been replaced with mystery somber
piano music plays as Sonic X plus his
new world it's a total tonal shift from
previous games Sonic now has puzzles to
solve from moving statues to reveal a
secret to completing Rhythm tasks or
simply racing from point A to point B
the variation is welcome as2 is a new
combat system which reminds me of a
Dragon Ball fight Sonic's homing attacks
take him up close and he can throw fists
and his Dodge attack and parries keep
him safe there are World bosses to find
and defeat and look at the size of these
guys it's like Shadow of the Colossus
Sonic Frontiers is a full price game
releasing on November 8th on the
PlayStation Xboxes and PC oh and switch
too nice
next Warhammer 40K Inquisitor Mata I've
teamed up with Nikon to showcase the
Ultimate Edition coming to PlayStation 5
and Xbox series X a top-down action RPG
in which we are tasked with purging the
chaos Scourge the original game released
in 2018 I remember running the assassin
class good times and now Inquisitor Mata
and all 25 plus DLCs are coming to Next
Gen 4K visuals are fully supported
thanks to updated textures cross gen
multiplayer is confirmed if you prefer a
squad by your side and also a local
co-op mode has been added exclusively
for the PS5 and Xbox series X there are
four classes to choose from the Tanki
nature and freedom of the Crusader the
glass Cannon of the Assassin the saika
with an insane number of powers to
harness and conjure and finally the tech
Adept which summons deadly beings to
fight alongside there's a class to suit
everyone if fast-paced tactical combat
is your thing surrounded by the Mystique
of the 40K Universe look out for
Inquisitor Mata Ultimate Edition from
October 27th and look there's a link in
the description too
[Music]
right oh let's talk about this month's
free to play games without a doubt the
big one is Call of Duty Warzone version
2.0 the Battle Royale game which once
rivaled Apex and fortnite is having a
facelift and many changes are coming
including a new game mode on the
battlefield side of things there is a
new map almasra which looks to be filled
with new locations yet look a little bit
closer and you'll see they are places we
have visited in the Modern Warfare
series to date Warzone 2.0 add swimming
and underwater combat as a car mechanic
a new Gulag system and a new zonal
system looting has been refined and it's
more like pubg these days and AI
soldiers are now present on the map and
protect rare loot and high-level weapon
loadouts Warzone 2.0 also adds a brand
new mode named DMZ and if you've played
tarkov you'll know what this is Mew and
your squad go into a hostile Zone with
one thing in mind to extract loot if you
are eliminated in The Game you lose the
loot you are holding so it's risk versus
reward what do you take in knowing that
you may not come back out with it once
Modern Warfare 2 fully releases more
info about Warzone 2.0 will follow the
full release hits us on November the
16th
[Music]
the second free game is Gundam Evolution
a class-based first-person shooter which
starts off feeling a lot like OverWatch
1 but there's enough tweaks to make it
its own game in its own right like this
everyone has a mech suit equipped with a
jet pack use it to fly hover Sprint or
Dash and you'll soon find that each suit
has more or less of that jetpack ability
depending on the general class and type
you choose matches are six versus six
and team Synergy is the core element to
winning matches building a team of Tanks
to take damage and Lead the Way Forward
adding a DPS unit to hit the opposition
with as many bullets as possible and all
of that backed up by support units that
heal oh and instead of a kill cam Gundam
Evolution uses a down but not out
mechanic which lets teammates be rezzed
by other members of the squad this means
while you are downed you can ping enemy
positions and still help your team I
quite like that with 12 Gundam suits
available right away and more to be
unlocked could Evolution rival over
watch too Gundam Evolution comes to
console on November 30th with a big push
for new content coming in December and
I'll be sure to tell you about that next
month
okay there's one more free game out this
month and it's a bit cringy I'll be
honest see for yourself cuties hacked oh
no someone stole my phone yep that's
really the title essentially it's a
Sonic's game a cursor is on the screen
and we reveal an image behind by slowly
blocking away the safe areas and not
touching the Hostile elements on screen
the blurb for the game says unlock the
door to the secretive contents of girls
phones yikes if this is your type of
game I'm not judging you I just don't
want to talk about it anymore deal deal
[Music]
back onto full price games well in fact
a few reduced price games so forty
dollars forty Euros 35 pounds and
something more fitting for the Halloween
season take a look at the Devil in Me
the fourth installment of the dark
pitches Anthology which is the spiritual
successor of the brilliant until dawn
like the other episodes in this series
The Devil in Me is effectively an
interactive drama in which we choose our
own adventure set in a creepy hotel as a
group of documentary makers visit a
replica of a series serial Killer's home
what could go wrong each decision
branches the path of the story and it's
highly likely two playthroughs will have
completely different conclusions Devil
in Me releases on November 18th on
Playstation Xbox and PC if you want
something closer in time to Halloween
and with more Hands-On gameplay check
out the chant traveling to an island
that feeds on negativity we play as Jess
as she faces her spiritual enlightenment
face on combining Survival action and
exploration our playthrough is impacted
by dialogue choices and actions as the
story continues it's time to really
understand what Secrets the island holds
the chant releases on November 3rd on
PS5 Xbox series and PC
[Music]
here's a game for your inner vampire
Hunter evil West a third person action
adventure set in the 18th century filled
with vampires and you play as a
character who's like a cowboy Van
Helsing named Jesse the combat is a
mixture of gun wielding and melee and
essentially you are a one-man Army
progressing to the epicenter of this
vampire issue along the way RPG elements
show their face as your weapon and
character can be adapted through skill
trees and upgrade paths all the action
is then broken up by environmental
puzzles November 22nd if that's your
thing on Playstation Xbox and PC there
are so many more games coming in
November here's a quick shout out to a
few Miles Morales is finally coming to
PC on November 18th with a completely
different skill set to Peter Parker
Spider-Man so if you have a PC that
isn't a potato I recommend it Resident
Evil lovers you should know that are
reverse the new game mode is here on
October 28th letting anyone who has
bought Village over the last year to
play it completely for free fighting
other real-life people playing survivors
of the legendary series hands off Jill
Valentine and of course there's a new
generation of Pokemon arriving this
month shame I'm not supposed to talk
about it here I just need help choosing
between scarlet and violet help me with
that please if you're still here at this
point thank you so much for your time
I'm Adam you're awesome it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time